ist ein wunderschöner Tag heute für
österreichische Bundesheer für die
Flieger Werft hier in Aigen und
insbesondere auch für das Land
Steiermark der zweite der modernsten
Hubschrauber den haben wir heute in
Empfang genommen insgesamt werden 36
werden hier werden dann im Endausbau am
Ende des Jahres 2028 12 dieser
modernsten Fluggeräte stationiert sein
und hier wird auch die Wartung für die
gesamte Flotte aller 36 stattfinden dazu
werden wir investieren auch noch nämlich
mehr als 40 Millionen Euro die dringend
notwendig sind und wir suchen noch
weiteres Personal
[Musik]
ja sie haben einfach ein einen
unglaublichen Leistungsgewinn im
Vergleich zu allen drei ist eher
vergleichbar mit dem Augusta Bell zu 12
Transporthubschrauber sowohl was die
Mitnahme von Passagieren betrifft die
lösch Menge die ich tragen kann die
Geschwindigkeit ist ungefähr doppelt so
hoch also ich habe in allen Bereichen
einen leistungszuwachen ja Leute ist ein
ausgezeichneter Hubschrauber nach wie
vor er ist einfach nur in die Jahre
gekommen das ist wie bei einem Oldtimer
wenn da in die Jahre kommt werden die
Ersatzteile sehr sehr teuer und wenn es
dieses Gerät nicht mehr gibt sonst auf
der Welt sind ja Ersatzteile nahezu
unleistbar und deswegen müssen wir die
Leute ausschneiden